salut à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau master class le samedi c'est le
jour du master class celui ci un petit
peu différent des autres job mais il va
être aussi une bascule entre ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant et la
continuité de cette chaîne peut-être
avez-vous remarqué que depuis le 1er
janvier depuis le lancement de la chaîne
j'ai essayé de faire un espèce de
progression pédagogique dans ce que je
vous offrirai c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que je ne réponds jamais aux questions
du type vas-y apprends-nous ça fait nous
ça si c'est pas cohérent avec la chaîne
pourquoi excellente question merci de
l'avoir posée parce que je n'explique
que ce que vous pouvez refaire en vrai
je me prends pas pour un formateur ou
quoi que ce soit j'ai pas du tout cette
prétention mais j'essaie que vous
puissiez avoir une progression au fur et
à mesure par exemple tout ce que j'ai
fait sur la mémoire peu ça semblait au
fur et à mesure pour faire grossir sa en
espèces d'un savoir global pareil pour
le mentalisme pareil pour les maths
pareil pour tous que j'aborde j'essaie
de réfléchir et arrêtez de vous dire ben
on dirait pas peut-être avez-vous
remarqué en tout cas j'espère qu'on
commence et quand même à passer des
paliers dans les explications du
dimanche par exemple dans les masters
classes on touche des choses qui sont de
plus en plus sensibles de plus en plus
complexes à faire et pourtant ça vous
paraît pas complexe puisque on a vu
plein de choses à un exemple concret
c'est la vidéo de dimanche dernier pour
deviner le prénom hockey de penser
quelqu'un dans une soirée je vais
continuer la chaîne dans cet état
d'esprit évidemment on va encore passer
des paliers
mais juste avant ça je pense qu'on est
au point d'équilibré où on devrait
pouvoir aborder un truc tout bête qui
nécessitait d'après moi un master class
c'est se sentir bien soi-même comment on
fait pour se sentir vraiment bien
intérieurement c'est même pas forcément
heureux c'est juste libre un con qu'on
ne venez pas de boulot vendent qu'on
n'ait pas de poids qui traîne quelque
part émotionnellement quand on aborde
les notions de développement de
mentalisme de mémoire même de culture je
me dis que c'est super qu'on s'ouvre à
plein plein de choses mais c'est bien de
se recentrer sur soi pour se libérer soi
même et être retirés rejoint d'ailleurs
un petit peu ce dont je parlais mercredi
dans la vidéo sur le rôle j'ai lu
énormément de livres là dessus il y en a
qui m'a marqué plus que les autres il
est très accessible c'est le vivre des
quatre accords toltèques je vais pas
vous détailler tout le contenu du livre
déjà parce que ça se fait pas il vous
recommande plutôt de le lire et c'est
pas un placement de produit gpat actions
chez les quatre accords toltèques le
même pas d'action j'ai les toltèques
d'ailleurs mais je vais vous citer
quelque chose fondamentale qui peuvent
vraiment vous aider et qui moi on était
une petite révélation quand j'ai lu ça
le premier accord que vous pouvez passer
avec vous même c'est de faire en sorte
que votre parole soit impeccable et ça
c'est le plus dur c'est très dur de
rentrer sur parole impeccable mais alors
ça fait un bien fou
alors ça englobe plein de choses le fait
de pas menti
le fait de pas critiquer les autres je
vais juste vous donner une métaphore qui
est magnifique l'auteur du livre
explique que dire du mal de quelqu'un
c'est un petit peu comme si on verse et
du poison dans un verre qu'on le buvez
soi même et qu'on espérait que ça fasse
mal à l'autre personne
cette image est très pertinente est très
révélatrice de ce qu'est une parade
impeccable
le deuxième accord que vous pouvez
passer avec vous même c'est de ne jamais
en faire une affaire personnelle ce que
font et disent les autres à votre sujet
ne vous concerne pas ça les concerne
peut même c'est d'ailleurs la position
que vous avez face à celui qui n'a pas
une parole impeccable si quelqu'un me
dit écoute fabien des vidéos c'est une
vue là c'est nul c nul arrête c'est
tellement pourri ce que tu fais ça ne
sert à rien et bien je ferai tout pour
que mentalement émotionnellement ça ne
me concerne pas pourquoi parce que c'est
son problème à lui c'est lui qui a
décidé trouvé ça nul est en fait
pourquoi elle trouve ça nul ça le renvoi
à quoi c'est tout un processus intérieur
à lui qui lui appartient et qui sûrement
reliés à ses propres angoisses à ses
propres peurs ou à ses propres attentes
mais c'est son affaire à lui c'est pas
la mienne et bien d'une manière générale
dans la vie n'en fait pas une affaire
personnelle
le troisième accord c'est de ne pas
faire de supposition sa complète un
petit peu le premier accord c'est un
petit peu la formule magique il faut que
vous arrêtiez de supposés à la place des
autres et c'est à dire de penser à la
place des autres ça n'a rien à voir avec
le fait d'être déductif et de prendre
des éléments dans gens pour comprendre
une situation s'ajuste rapport avec le
fait de supposées pour tous à tort et à
travers que ce soit en amitié en amour
professionnellement on passe notre temps
à faire ça à tirer des plans sur la
comète et à se planter ne fait pas de
suppositions
ça vous permettra de ne pas vous
alourdir encore une fois
émotionnellement pour rien le quatrième
accord je vous laisserai le découvrir
dans le livre si vous voulez lire il ya
aussi toute introduction qui est très
intéressante toute la philosophie
toltèques aussi est très bien vous êtes
vraiment extrait les trois choses que je
trouve vraiment essentiel est que moi
j'ai gardé à la lecture il ya des années
de ça ces trois règles là elles peuvent
vous aider vraiment à à s'alléger un
petit peu de certaines angoisses et tout
ça et a retrouvé un petit peu un état je
vous ai dit c'est pas vraiment un état
de heureux mais un état de bien-être au
moins être bien c'est à dire ne pas être
mal ça paraît logique indique comme ça
j'en ai conscience c'est un petit
bouquin qui est pas très longue montée
en format poche vous ne mettrez le lien
dans la description
je me suis dit je vais vous parler de
celui là plutôt que d'un autre j'aurais
pu parler des cartes au les pouvoirs
l'instant présent j'aurais pu aussi vous
parler de la trilogie de bouquins de
walsh mais là c'est aussi un peu plus
compliqué à aborder au départ si vous
connaissez déjà les
or toltèques la dot livres qui sont cool
comme aux ponots ponot mais c'est un peu
plus chez perd donc il faut connaître un
petit peu tous univers là et c'est un
avis perso il n'y a pas de souci avec ça
je crois que pour aller plus loin dans
le mentalisme il fallait juste qu'on se
mettre d'accord sur l'utilisation du
mentalisme qu'une utilisation légère
divertissante pour soi même pour un
développement aussi de soi mais le
mental et s'est pas fait à la base pour
prendre aux autres ou pour manipuler ou
pour se glorifier près des autres
partant de ce principe là il est
important d'être en accord avec soi-même
j'espère que ce master class un petit
peu différent un peu original vous aura
plu me demande un peu comment vous allez
le recevoir ce sera un des seuls sur
cette thématique là tu auras sur la
chaîne mais j'espère qu'il vous
apportera une ou deux phrases marquantes
et que vous irez lire le bouquin sur
internet ou dans une bibliothèque où
vous le ferez prêter et faire vos
propres conclusions bien sûr il n'y a
pas de ya pas d obligation de d'admettre
sa où il trouvait ça cool mais lisez le
c'est intéressant je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end demain c'est
l'explication de tours que j'ai pas
encore écrite donc je ne sais pas encore
ce que je vais vous faire demain si
cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas le
premier accord du mental vlog qui est de
mettre des pouces en l'air
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne bien sûr merci à vous tous d'être
présent merci à tous ceux aussi qui font
les sous titre vous assurez comme des
chefs le mental blog c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant un an donc rendez vous
demain à 11 heures
ciao